[Music]
breath of the wild discoveries continue
to occur no matter how much we think
they're going to slow down players seem
to push the game's limits even farther
blss or bow lift smuggling slide is one
of the biggest new additions to the
ever-growing list of discoveries found
in the legend of zelda breath of the
wild while wind bombs and bullet time
bounces are still a staple form of
travel for casual players and
speedrunners alike blss offers a new way
of long distance travel without too much
setup needed if you enjoy a breath of
the wild content make sure to like this
video as we continue to cover this game
still to this day
the story behind this discovery as with
most breath of the wild finds begins
with the glitch hunters bouncing ideas
off each other through twitter the most
recent trend was people finding new ways
to smuggle a technique of making link
hold items he's not supposed to japanese
user pd conten then found this strange
smuggle that led to link holding a bow
and an object at the same time glitch
hunter legend of link then decided to
mess with this find as well and on
september 4th found that by doing this
glitch holding b then mounting a small
ledge will cause link to levitate and
glide at incredible speeds so now you're
wondering if you can do it for yourself
you can and it's pretty easy i'll teach
you first how to do it for yourself at
home then for the more hardcore audience
explain the mechanics behind how this
works
all you need to perform this glitch is a
shield a bow a liftable object such as a
bomb and a small ledge to step up on
first place a bomb or object in front of
link then hold zl to bring up only his
shield in front and no weapon in his
hand then press zr and a in quick
succession
this should be fairly easy as you'll see
link holders bow then lift the object
with the bow still in his hands the next
part is slightly harder as you'll have
to jump press b then pause as fast as
possible the succession of b to pause
needs to be pretty quick but holding zl
while doing this makes the process a
little bit easier
especially with larger objects then from
the pause menu unequip your shield
now simply aim your bow and then press b
from this point hold b then approach any
small ledge and step up over it going
over it will cause you to start hovering
above the ground keep in mind that you
absolutely must hold down any walking
direction down at all times as letting
go of the stick and that releasing b
will also cause link to fall try out
different items as every object
interacts differently with how link
moves to maximize on this technique
though the bomb version is the most
controllable tilting the left joystick
directly left to right quickly with the
held object towards the camera you can
cause link to gain speed quickly all in
all it might take a couple tries but
it's not too difficult to pull off now
for people wondering about the technical
magic behind this i'll explain as best
as possible but don't be too discouraged
if this part confuses you as you don't
need to understand this to perform the
glitch anyways
this is a succession story of several
glitches being combined together first
why is it even called bow lift smuggling
slide well it's incorporating both a
normal bow smuggle and an item lift
smuggle at the same time
and when you perform this glitch you
also trigger another glitch called
b-lock which has a side effect called
bow sliding hence why it's called bow
lift smuggling slide or blss okay crazy
acronym aside what exactly are these
glitches and why is this happening let's
go a little more in depth when link
performs the step up animation link goes
from walking on the ground then stepping
up then walking on the ground again
pretty simple but stepping up while bose
sliding causes this strange locked state
of never finishing a step up meaning
he's in a limbo state of actually never
being on solid ground but since blss is
a combination of both sliding and
smuggling when link steps up he is
forcefully pushed out of his normal step
up onto an invisible layer while
actually never finishing his animation
okay interesting but what makes link
move so strangely and how is he getting
pushed around that's where the smuggling
comes in there's two versions found so
far of smuggling a liftable object in
breath of the wild
one method causes collision with objects
away from link as if link were heavier
the other method pushes link away from
the object as if link were lighter this
is why this glitch has incredible
movement capabilities while holding the
object like this the object itself is
pushing itself into link's hitbox
causing this movement in the air any
quick movement aggravates the held
object to push link more and more
causing you to gain massive speed while
doing this trick because the object is
constantly nudging into link over and
over while floating with no friction to
stop him this all combined gives link
infinite flight in breath of the wild
in any case understanding all the insane
mechanics isn't really necessary but
understanding is positive and negatives
is such as the amazing infinite distance
capability with absolutely no stamina
needed from gliding compared to other
techniques and no health required
compared to techniques such as wind
bombs but blss by itself has no ability
to gain height upwards and there's a
possibility of actually going too fast
and hitting breath of the wild's
built-in speed cap which will cause link
to slow down back to a crawl or even
stop him dead in his tracks and fall
down but despite the positives and
negatives is this glitch fun to do
absolutely you should give it a shot and
zoom across hyrule yourself it's loads
of fun
[Music]
if you simply want to see blss in action
stick around now to see me cross the
entire map in roughly 4 minutes with
this amazing trick and of course for
everything else breath of the wild stick
right here on gamespot
one more note before i leave you to the
scenic flight if you want to do what i'm
doing don't pan the camera around too
much like i did on this trip it's mostly
for you viewers to get some decent views
during the trip this will often cause
more loading lag as you travel so for
the least amount of lag try not to turn
the camera too much okay enjoy
that
[Music]
[Music]
hit
[Music]
[Music]
you